one signature celebration can often
cement an athlete's Legacy for the rest
of their career and in 2019 Alex Morgan
did just that with the iconic sipping
tea celebration but while there have
been many interpretations of what her
celebration meant what's the real story
behind it the US and England were tied
one to one with the World Cup final
birth at stake until Morgan Tedder would
give the U.S the lead moments after she
scored what would end up being the
winning goal for her team she celebrated
by sipping tea and people were not happy
Morgan received backlash from many
English supporters and players who
described the incident as distasteful
and disrespectful English broadcaster
Piers Morgan even went as far as to say
that it was a declaration of war Alex
Morgan clarified after the game that the
celebration had nothing to do with the
history between the two nations in fact
she said her act was simply a tribute to
Game of Thrones star Sophie Turner and
that's the t is a phrase that the
actress often uses on her social media
and that inspired Morgan her celebration
may still be viewed as a shot to English
fans worldwide but nevertheless still an
iconic moment in women's sports history